a couple road dogs what been a long road
for both us Rashad was just talking
about selling tickets on the road yeah
but don't like a Thursday show packed
you and I don't make your voice all
gravelly like you've been on the road
forever like Ron White I don't need you
going it's been a long road for both of
us don't ever lump the two of us
together would what are you doing stop
making a noise that's a Ron white noise
miles you and I have put don't say you
and I - don't be
look he's frequent flyer compared to me
I'm I'm a Road camel you know I'm a I'm
a Road tortoise you're Road tortoise
even do it for a hot SEC there's that
tortoise that lived 250 years born like
the 17th see that it's 250 so they all
live pretty fun this one in particular
lived 250 years he's like the Betty
White of the tortoises yeah like [ __ ]
a he's doing some [ __ ] right like what
maybe or is he just in trees like it's
all this thing I was thinking about that
yeah there is he's 186 yeah now there's
another tortoise that's 200 years old
that's the old it either way though
that's really all 529 holy fly 529
behind that yeah I just I just find what
is it what's the oldest animal in the
world I can tell you before you answer
the arctic shark they think that they
are from carbon dating and they it's
hard for them to find them right think
they've only been seen like well they
they apparently will eat polar bears and
things but the arctic shark is can be
600 years old as how old Arctic shark is
I bet he has seen some [ __ ] you say
babies on the go shark they look like
ghosts
yeah they look very strange he look like
you killing with your hands yeah and
what they're huge four hundred years old
Wow
[ __ ] Greenland shark longest living
river four hundred years I want to do
what they do I guess I just have to stay
cold and move closely finish nothing but
fish and the occasional seal apparently
and the occasional polar bear the
occasional polar bear dude how about I
thought we had a guest today and I
Andrew Schultz forgot brilliant idiots
in he's a
comic I thought and I arranged this I
thought he was on the podcast today yeah
Dewayne form I even got flustered except
that he was late to our show
yeah and I sent him angry text he's like
dude it's next week and then I just sent
him a picture of my dick when my bad
yeah here's a good way to the Arctic
shark my bat and he does it with
Charlemagne who I'm a huge fan of I'd
like to get Charlemagne oh I like that
leave you both of the month yeah really
good podcast I like Charlie dude he's
really an ogre you like Andrew - I'm
sure feed him like sure the third
singing Beyonce no no I'm sure you know
you guys haven't seen him I'm gonna go
get Pedro oh that's I'd rather have
Charlemagne that makes em feel like [ __ ]
no right it's all I said like whoa I
want both ho whomp both he's got a good
hair hair on him that's a great jacket
16 jacket is steal your girl he's not a
bad-looking kid hmm tall tall dark hair
in California but he's New York comic
okay all right California Tomac yeah
there he is there he is there is he's on
next week I apologize I would my life be
different if I had heard that thick no
not at all
no no not a thing cuz you got shot hair
dude huh that's the shop do yeah he's a
good-looking dude yes here's better mine
we're watching what's that what's the
[ __ ] movies Bradley Cooper star is
born' have you seen it I've not you need
to it's been out for hot seconds yeah
I'm not trying to spoil anything but
yeah it's been out long in three months
I can I'm a chatty it's okay because we
all know remake yeah we all know how
dude first of all really good movie yeah
a little depressing
yeah Bradley Cooper sings like a goddamn
angel in it yeah dude he's in the subway
live at the Oscars with her but I'm
gonna tell you this just really quickly
he sings he's had about as much singing
as I have yes so in other words he was
like for this daddy yes well since aw
yeah but still he's amazing in this
yeah but his hair in the movie he looks
like you're straight-up dying piece oh
yeah okay girl goes I think you could
grow your hair out like that I went why
I don't know he has great said of here I
can I've grown it long before
I don't think it would do the trick with
you my hair be more like the guy on the
right mm I could do it though it's gonna
take quite some time he he had like Bono
and any veteran those guys like like
will watch him from them knowing things
he got advice from them know he'd
literally Willie Nelson son he was they
they basically just lived together and
Willie Nelson son was I'm the guitar and
singing like how to do certain and then
they're so involved in the movie you
know it's Willie Nelson's son who's also
a musician is in the movie now he's in
the band Wow he's like the bass player
the movies really really [ __ ] good
yeah you know and everything so like I'm
the guy if you tell me Black Panthers
best movie in the world yes I I'm like
you know what everyone likes it about it
makes me not like that yeah but with
this movie everyone liked it and so I
didn't see it in the theater and then
[ __ ] I don't have TV right now so I just
have digital streaming and so I watched
this last night [ __ ] good movie man
so well done he's however very at the
end sad very depressed yeah very very
depressed so so Bradley I almost shed I
know that Bradley like they told him
they were like dude your first movie
cannot be a remake stars born
you cannot write songs and stand singing
it you're not a musician
this isn't Sam got Lady Gaga he was like
he was like I'm doing it and they
they're like oh come on like Todd
Phillips is like he produced it he's
like dude come on the producing partner
said come on and he pulled it off and
Todd said to me when he before I didn't
care he goes it's it's it's a great
movie and he's gonna be he's gonna be
Clint Eastwood he's gonna be the next
play nice work dude he should win an
Oscar for this I agree
but they won't give it to him because
for some reason well good-looking or so
all they give it to him I hope you do
this much work I don't even get a either
want like you know I want Bradley Cooper
get or I want the guy who played Freddie
Mercury to get it yeah but that would
like well this was up this he's so good
in this man that's how he's married and
that's a pretty that's a pretty school
against yellow hey sure you see
Bradley's girl sure have
mmm-hmm that's what being the most
famous man in the world get he was
always he was always getting I did
Bradley was always getting that don't
kid yourself you know what's weird is
Bradley for like there he looked a
little bit like an [ __ ] now I think a
heartthrob it was always a heartthrob
dude little totally get a little taller
a little better look in his eyes or blue
a six for Bradley 6-1 6-1 every bit of
it almost six - probably one 185 over 90
look at dude I'm growing that's what
that was at the flea I'm coming that was
at the comment you do it you're coming
look at him dude I'm doing it imma grow
my hair I'll be but I wouldn't eat
Cooper if you have hair like that I wish
I guess when they were in a fight I
think at the douchey is delicious
debbye cute they have kiddos chin now I
have kiddos but but he's so into his kid
like he's so into changing diapers and
everything he's just super dad
everything that [ __ ] does here
is if your daddy not even changed
diapers you ain't [ __ ] everything that
guy does I can is is to the nth degree
just when Bradley does A's the most
disciplined human being borogrove ever
what I told you Ben Bruno trained him
for American sniper and I came in to do
my workout on the on the trap bars the
the thing and I go who the [ __ ] was
lifting all this things like Oh Bradley
was like this it was like same [ __ ] I
was doing he's strong he's big he's big
kid strong she's daughter and Laird
she's Saint shake God early edition
Jackie he was working out with a trainer
a long time ago and he was like dude I I
was like he goes I was doing snatches
whether it was like 225 I was like I are
setting more than that because I don't
always be I was able to lift it it was
crazy
where's he's from originally
Pennsylvania its promoter Brian I was
only an only child dad died of cancer
the odds dad was a teacher didn't grow
up with money didn't grow up with
anything Josh that movie is good man
went it went to theater school
he's his big breakout was the hangover
though his big break was really wedding
crashers that I'm her he called The
Hangover you so oh yeah well the
hangover was the [ __ ] what are you
crashes though you kind of disliked them
yeah he's an ass yeah but but you saw
how good of an actor he was and from
wedding crap shakes him for everybody
wanted to be in it then he did a play
with Julia Roberts on Broadway and that
was kind of like that's where everybody
was like all this [ __ ] guy can really
act you know he just he's a really
really good actor because on my hair bro
he understands the craft deeply he loves
the craft yeah yeah your man has long
you get off his nut your man has long
hair huh mm-hmm
he's been growing it out uh every time
he grows it out he grows it out for
about a year to two years and then cuts
it off and donates it now don't take any
offense this but you guys have the same
hair yeah basically I just look pretty
similar yeah we went to a restaurant uh
one day and the waitress said Hey ladies
what are we having it was a guy and she
was mortified but my man was like what
well I'm us I'm great [ __ ] hair yeah
yeah good hair yeah three days I ran
I've seen that play hey did your hair
like softest [ __ ] mm-hmm but also I feel
like Asian people - dragon races Asian
people in general their hair always
looks like well like you never see it
like frizzy or like broken ends like
it's always healthy as [ __ ] you know I'm
saying agents do have good hair I will
say like Indians in particular their
hair go their hair is usually what's
used for wigs and weaves oh yeah yeah a
lot of in you girls will grow out their
hair cut it and sell it so they get a
lot of good money for it is there any
Asians with curly hair yeah my mom has
curly hair really yeah she's like never
seen it but it's a rarity you ever seen
it yeah no I have never never never
but your mama does mmm like that Sandra
Oh type of like curly I think that's
[ __ ] my position like yeah looks like
it's made that way but no like naturally
kind of like wavy hair that might be I
would be yeah it's very rare though it's
like almost like a unicorn yeah wow yeah
this girl keeps popping up dude how I
tell you I'm the grandma here I'm saying
can I be honest with you I'm quietly a
little not only am i jealous I'm a
little I'm a little mad well why because
it's just more of you're gonna you're
gonna be showing off with your [ __ ]
hair I'm gonna do that now the forest
you have to grow your hair long just
like but I favor you what I wish you
would do is embrace your meat head yeah
your
your strength and power a little bit
more your - you better play it down dude
look at that
yeah I mean that yeah that is a star
raising but you're not like that I'm
sorry about what oh you're - I could do
my lesson me I'm gonna use this word and
it's gonna hurt you you're a thicky now
let me explain although there you go
I mean that guy he's big he's as big as
you are isn't he he's about the same
height he's thinner he's better it's
more of an ectomorph I was thick
nope oh he's not as thick no I thought
he was no I thought he was ready
nobody's really nobody's really thicker
than you you're a giant a nobody
well you're a giant oh but if I mean
your email what I mean is that you're
you're you are and you are arresting
there's gonna hurt you you're arresting
to 65 to 60 I know you're like no no but
you're if I if I forced you six yeah
you're arresting to 60 I'm arresting 165
like you're not dieting or anything
you're 260 yeah you're just but even
when you're in shape like you look good
right now your big guy you'll actually
look cuff in I started from behind but
you're I put you on a scale right now
and thickie thicky the numbers I'm
getting are six four two six four and
that's what I'm getting
I'm PI here see maybe even more no not
more I don't know but I'm telling you
unfortunately work out for two weeks man
I've just got my other work then we're
well then we roughly sick we're we're
well we're over to six oh now listen
that's fine
because you're you're such a strong big
guy it's just how you are
you're an obviously on the biggest end
up in the world yeah you're an athlete
you're a big strong athlete well no I
got a kick out of [ __ ] Eddie Bravo on
the podcast saying I don't think Brennan
could finish Jo in jujitsu and I was
like and I was I felt like saying Eddie
you are an all you're an amazing jujitsu
guy but we need to understand a couple
of things the gorilla will finish both
of you immediately why we had to go down
this road man no but I mean I bring out
it before guys the economy structure
last night goes we should fire bro ador
got the commentators kidding I went
excuse me he's kidding though how he's
got my boys Derek and a song I'm a the
[ __ ] see timeout he is he's security he
does like boxing I'm like he's dead
there she goes yeah he really wants to
spar you oh and I went why do I do it
why why
man enjoy that why can't I just live
enjoy that damn how long does 2014 by
the way I'd rather wait look at the size
of you compared to all of us look at the
size of you don't you're here though I
had nice hair tonight
Cobham was that you look that's five
years ago did you know why father time
we've been doing fight campaign for a
hot second haven't went yeah if all the
time makes a difference look at that
[ __ ] dude you were fighting that I think
or just retired probably and she was now
I'm yeah so so so I don't so the point
I'm making is this if you grow your hair
long it might accentuate it might
accentuate your size you might be the
giant guy on earth longer yeah I see
what your eyes do you put down I know
you're thinner no I hear no I didn't say
that I don't want you to get there I'm
not trying to be super no you're not
gonna be that I'm comes like I'm not
deadly I'm coming just like I'm not
gonna be thick and I want to be you're
not gonna be thin but I can like who's
Brock Wrigley that's her the sets I
don't want that that was that guy he's
annoying me that's that's Thor real-life
Thor let's know the problem is he's got
he comes in he's best friends with his
main and all you see is a main and he
like dude you just got Congrats on on
your on your main it's just too much and
it's that long it's a very feminine yeah
and it's also so well done and he's just
a big old liar so there's that yeah
there's their big issue mr. Keith Urban
dish the huh that takes a lot and even
if you're Keith Urban that takes too
much time
oh I know that drives me nuts I know I
see him at the comedy store sometimes no
giant guys yeah how many store doing
what yeah boy in the back I know he
knows Chris D'Elia he's about six five
he's a huge guy and he's a fitness model
really jacked people off with his hair
now he's a straight dude he's a straight
dude he's married to the day he'll make
you hurt he'll hurt you
he'll hurt you because he is a beautiful
man and a fitness model but at the same
time right now he he's gay we date who
he wants and when it comes to females
I'm sorry but the problem is you don't
do you
that well you know he's too hot he dates
girls like are you into that cat yeah
when I'm into that guy that Thor died of
course look at his shoulders years ago
go to his tank top he's a good looking
objectively I do agree with you that
like that pretty you want a little too
pretty in that you want to rephrase that
he's - he has a lot of maintenance
take a look like if he has to go get
highlights but I don't like using me
[ __ ] there and then looking this here
going you guys the problem yeah that's
the problem he's very thick girl it's
hard you put it on let me just turn
around it's hard not to be vain when
you're that good-looking he's a he's a
good legit six four he didn't shave that
beard he ain't [ __ ] I don't know buddy I
think he's probably born I don't think
so
you've seen dudes when they will they
lose the beard what's sad is when I see
that I go I gotta get serious about my
weightlifting I saw myself on the Rogen
when I took my shirt off too skinny
oh you're too skinny I mean does anyone
like their body though do you know
anyone who's like I'm good I mean have
you met that guy that guy's not good try
that guy yeah even you are your urine
secured by everywhere all's you know
anyone who's like I'm good yeah well
that guy's serious well do me a favor if
you see him walking towards you on the
street cross the street cuz you want no
part of that if I see one cross street
I'm gonna go to the nearest [ __ ] food
truck buy a [ __ ] falafel and jam it
right down a stupid throat you can only
ride falafels all you get you know what
you want what I want you to do is I want
you to go nice tits nice tits
you got some round titties I'm gonna say
excuse me sir are you nuts or from Thor
walk in here I guess your mom Chris was
making fun of him and then he became
friends with Chris he's got a good say
apparently he's a good guy a sense of
humor regular guy he looks hilarious I'm
gonna have trouble well there you go
he's not he's not he's not weak as Rogen
would say it he is the dick route yeah
he's gotta be spilt
look he's built the kids built your
congrats man yeah yeah but you got to
stop with that yeah you got to stop with
if you if you can shake your hair out
and and it's and it looks like the kind
of hair I want to hold on because I'm
taking you from last time you shook your
hair up well I probably when I was I
never have even when I was I remember
being [ __ ]
13 year
years old in Saudi Arabia and my friend
Michael scales making fun of gone Brian
because my hair was straw it had the
consistency of strong oh yeah it just
sucked nah it sucked in general it was
just I had shitty hair and I was what
let's say I'm a genie let Sam
Will Smith a giant blue genie and I come
up to yo yo I'm Callan I'll give you 40
pounds of straight muscles you me thick
II give me a thick E or I give you the
best hair in the world best hair in the
world 40 pounds of muscle you can't have
just 40 pounds of muscle because I'd
have to have the frame for it promise I
don't have the frame uh I need the frame
what's the Showtime picture there on the
red carpet right next to that who's that
who's my darling darling ex-girlfriend
zet who was amazed rollin on her oh you
look good in that picture though yeah
yeah your eyes are fully wide open and
you don't look tired at all huh zoom in
chin for [ __ ] I got my terrible outfit
that was a Gucci suit though she was I
loved her she was so beautiful
she still is did you like this yeah
sometimes they catch it and I loved I
thought you were [ __ ] sweet they're
how you're feeling yourself they're a
little bit I'm just Deb look I'm just
tired you should get that little birdie
on your on your arm but yeah they look
she's a little mousy a little birdie she
was a special fierce little gal well
yeah real Tomcat in the sack real real
Peter Pan ish in the sack yep but just a
just a force of nature a little force
yeah also could have been a huge star
though well but what happen things
happen you know in life are you still
friends with her yeah I still keep in
touch what did he do she's married in
Connecticut oh that's cool she's at
Graper how long did you guys date long
time two years over sad there you go
there's another one of me yeah
and now take a look at mine what was the
red Club take a look at my gorgeous wife
now same there you go
that was one light my lady was young too
bad you can't see there dude look at
your here there yeah yeah
the other one he's one of the other ones
with that with Mawile people [ __ ] she
was so gorgeous man look at her she is
gorgeous but look at her now
look at you make you the duck lips with
your best body that that woman there
right there the one mother my children
she was 26 - I'm telling you that she
had the best body I've ever seen him I
think you just scroll in her she had say
that on her scrolling you can't tell
what she's there what she's working with
no you don't know what she's ready I in
on another level
Amanda come in sweats and she's really
pretty [ __ ] she was a huge mom to me
but her body Hey her body
hey forget about it hey yeah yeah I have
to take a run bro hey what what why man
why are you getting low dude your chin
is going into your chest and you got
devious eyes man your eyes are all small
dude let me grow my hair out
take a run how about when you came to my
no no don't do that man isn't all energy
you can't take our on it my look at her
look at her man oh man
I'll get you though you're distracting
me oh I'm [ __ ] hey who's this Shh
hey you got a piece of [ __ ] on your arm
over there Amanda look at that look at
me man I'm just seeing that waving
friends dear girl oh yeah I'm gonna talk
a bunch of red it came to my house and
is me and my wife answered we were in
like our our PJs like a letter at night
we're in comfy clothing and we had our
we had bare feet on and he yeah and you
were returning me something you were
returning something and you go and
you're like ah here you got on that and
you were fighting still and you were
just looking down on us and you go you
know I could kill you both right no I
said that I could kill you I just stomp
thump your heads together and you would
die do you know that I would do we know
this that was so weird
Santa Paul cuz we looked all small
involved apologize yes all codes yeah he
look like a giant you both have your
robes on your furry robes
it was so dude how about I have all
these workers at my house right now
right doing stuff on the back yard and
the inside I can't wait for them to be
[ __ ] gone the begun I think today or
tomorrow they're doing all the stuff the
house there's a ton of mexicanos in my
house I'm docking right 12 to 14 a lot
of that's a lot of men well yeah well my
girl has a body from Mars and she
decides and she's Mexican as [ __ ] yeah
and she decides to roll around and just
her [ __ ] tight that's a broad on the
top you can't do that now can't do that
she's - dude you're [ __ ] up some work
she'll chill [ __ ] off everybody well
know that I'm like how are you guys two
days late and I tell you hey put some
[ __ ] this is like third lane that's why
are you doing you can't walk around like
that when we ride guys working that and
my girl when she was you know 26 or
something she came out board with no
Braun and the t-shirt the craziest hits
of all time the craziest hits of all
time and a body and I go I go I got men
if there's a rapist in that group
somewhere like men you know you don't
know who you're dealing with a bunch of
men are working in your house you don't
know what the fuss is gonna know could
be 10 guys there's always one criminal
no I go you don't get the [ __ ] inside
you might bring the criminal out in the
regular man yeah way you're that good I
told my girl like they were like yeah
good I'm gonna commit the crime and go
to jail it's worth it
no they were looking at answer titties
out and playing basketball I'm your
basketball court now I'm playing
basketball nice walk by my pool anyway
so I went by my pulled up the basketball
court I'm sorry man exhausted your bi
knows full court leaders full court and
all new basketballs so many lights under
playing basketball I see her down I see
all the guys staring out I go jump come
up here she's like why am i come up here
you get your [ __ ] tits on your ass at
the back she was [ __ ] annals of you
know not an animal now they're men know
if they get a [ __ ] or severely good man
they're fabulous yeah get inside
I said that I said to her bad Meryl
never forgot that I go you I go you get
inside now get inside like I got mad she
was sorry you can't do that I can't walk
around like that but it's a bit they're
not bad dudes no I'm like I would I
would probably jack off the vile that's
right that's right
there's none the same thing you you know
what you deserve you should be catcalled
right now they should all cat call right
now you've earned it you've earned it
yeah it's a weird thing it's just that
it that's how as a guy you know how the
inner machinations of a man
mind you're like ah but I tell you what
like it's super uncomfortable like I go
this coffee shop and there's this guy's
about as straight as a [ __ ] San
Francisco Road and it's [ __ ] it's him
and like all of them are there and I can
feel like as soon as I walk in I just
want my coffee man so I can I'm just
like there we go there we go well you
know it you're like what what do you
want like just just a coffee they light
out a dark roast right whatever man I'll
take them they light out cream I'm like
just give me the goddamn cup of joe man
no one's getting sucked today all right
how about that just give me the car they
want to sleep my nobody's ginza you're a
boyfriend material
do you know what now I feel so
uncomfortable I stopped going in for
coffee and I think God girls deal with
this all all the time all the time all
the time it's no joke remember I'm you
suck one dick every and I get that all
one dick remember a game of Thrones
you suck one dick you [ __ ] one goat
you're a goat [ __ ] it's so unfair do
the thing yeah yeah I build these I
build these walls nobody calls me a wall
builder I cure all these people - I'm
gonna call me a doctor I [ __ ] one go now
I'm the goat [ __ ] [ __ ] Game of
Thrones when these men show up and
they're in an encampment and what season
say the night is long what season it was
I think the last one okay that's one six
and the guy was a warrior the giant guy
goes you have to get out of here and
they're like now they were nice guys
they're not nice they're coming back
what would they come back for and he
says yeah food and you have women and
that's right and of course they come
back cool story dude they come back but
back in the day when you had women that
was you knew that those [ __ ]
were coming and they're gonna come take
your women that's how [ __ ] up history
is look at that great movie that party
trail bro the man of many faces
ah that was a week you know about yeah I
see my part I find a week did you know
they cancelled uh well this this I think
he's come in April right and then a game
of Thrones
yeah I can't [ __ ] wait but then also
you know Punisher is done on Netflix
yeah and people like God gives us the
season two's amazing she was watching it
no they were but Disney is taken pulling
off all comics [ __ ] on Netflix they're
like oh we'll have our own streaming
server we're not gonna give you Punisher
Netflix spider-man no no was taken at
all yeah that's right that might be
right Ken each there goes click on that
you were just on a chin click on that
link I hear good things about that actor
he's a good guy yeah right [ __ ] yeah
amazing I play baseball to play d1
baseball amazing actor the guy who saw
me in the house is his best friend oh
really
yeah you've seen it was the three of
them always playing he was talking about
how he's always struggling and like
needed food at lunch and stuff like you
saying this is like right before you got
walking right dude he goes he was
struggle City oh yeah but just kept
grinding and then got walking dead
that's the reality of what we do yeah as
I was driving down the highway I see a
huge available for him and Punisher
you're so proud of so cool crazy
he's let's it's a guy can't Club Netflix
Marvel purge is complete there you go
the streaming giant cancel the remainder
of its Marvel TV shows on Monday the
Punisher and Jessica Jones no one's
watching that deadline first reported
Netflix released the second season
Punisher
alright we are grateful for Mario 5
years of the partnership thank you
passionate yeah there you go so it's not
because it no one's watching cuz
Punisher was a [ __ ] huge hit yeah
yeah yeah dude you have to answer a call
from your wifey mm-hmm and I told you to
I said hey
hi hi hey why is that
why have you draw out your words is that
kind of sound like a valley girl why
like a why can't a guy be like hey I
mean without people going oh the gay
guys stole that that's a gay culture
stole Hawaii why would I be considered
like why would somebody jump to the
conclusion assume that I'm gay if I went
high because they stole that they tell
that's their you know yeah culture
vultures I'm gonna write that and mess
with me might I have a bit about that hi
what other words why if I add a bunch of
oh you know what else is a very feminine
homosexual word [ __ ] if you say it the
wrong like I'm like you stupid [ __ ] I'm
mostly talking about a female I don't
know how thank you but if I go [ __ ] I
don't know maybe if I go give her that
burger [ __ ] it's not so much the word
it's how you say it that's a French
batch you're crazy bids
no but if I was like bad [ __ ] please
see all that's good but feel like a
stupid [ __ ] then it's like okay he's
straight but if it but I wonder if
they're verses bad
you're a bad shape at what's this chin
almost sexual slang angel-food
homosexual male pilot currently serving
in the Air Force
I don't know how legitimate is he'll say
yeah it sounds like trolling stuff
mm-hmm
yeah it'll chicken a chapstick lesbian a
chicken a young Chicken Hawk
what is a chicken as a young homosexual
male seeking older men but please that
ain't no chicken that's a hot a sugar
cottaging i British slang for hooking up
in public bathrooms you guys you guys
cottaging again oh there you go fanny
bellhop gay male employed by the
hospitality industry such as a concierge
yeah so they come up drop off that mint
wait go back up it's freezing on me
oh they're a Girl Scout okay now you're
just taking all the words military man
on leave currently seeking sex a Girl
Scout operation a [ __ ] a show-off
fish-and-chips a 90s British slang for
the spouse and children with married
heterosexual ever okay okay you don't
get fisheye hips
this is [ __ ] yeah a lounge lizard so
new frequents bars trying to pick up
other people's mate well that the gays
just don't get lounge lizard I feel like
you and I came started dropping Lana
legit quite some time ago
lounge lizard was always used for like
just do to hang out yeah I could balloon
this yeah yeah what's up ladies did we
make a t-shirt go blameless lizards a
years ago whatever hang time ago think
so couple want to lamb lizard mmm-hmm
[Music]
when you drag things out as well you can
be very creepy you have any gay friends
cat mmm-hmm you do yeah feel like most
girls do yeah I feel like most girls
have like a couple sprinkle then are
they asian know mostly [ __ ] acting
what does that mean
well that mean just that like the
thespians are like the attract the Lions
like the New York the New York theater
scene has a lot of gay men in it just
theater in general yeah that's why
that's where this your friend fashion I
hate her yeah that's right music less
huh my corn Eddie Bravo well Jeannie any
gay friends if I do them told me but I
do have like bisexual humble have you
told that utopian head like Jones
yourself no not yet okay you can always
tell if I do I haven't addressed in the
Marriott no yeah I met um I did a movie
and the kid on the movie who was one of
our pas
was very very stiff his body was very
stiff no problem and I did the movie
with Jane Lynch who is herself gay and I
hope that I'm not out of her I'm sure
I'm sure I'm not and Jane said
if Jane Lynch I'll tell you I'm sure
she's a change that my ear to the ground
Jane said he's gay help do you think
that's holding her and she said I love
her so much Johanna King love Jane Lane
40 year old and she's a great person I
got I was so privileged I got to spend
two months with her and I love how you
thought you were having her yeah she
couldn't give she was always very she
was always up she was always like very
open first time I met her we talked but
but but she um she basically she said
she saw this kid and he was so his body
was so tight and she said I think that's
because he's gay comes from a very
religious background and his body is not
letting him be that way and I was like
that's a really deep thing to kind of
read into I was like I don't think she
goes she goes she goes I'll guarantee it
I took the kid out to dinner and I he
was all dizzy he was probably 22 or
something like Kayla but it turns out
his dad was well he was always there
he's always helping us so I took him out
to dinner and his dad was I guess a
preacher or some kind of a religious you
know man and and and I and we started
talking and I said now now let me ask
you I was like what's going on you know
do you feel and I said I said I'm gonna
ask them be careful but it doesn't
matter no big deal I don't care but do
you think that there's any maybe and
that maybe maybe there's some truth to
you feel a little confused about your
sexuality maybe and your dad's very
religious do you think how well he goes
he goes I've known for I've been working
with this kid but I didn't know him very
well
for but he'd never tell me about it he'd
never talk about you know he never
talked about it
he was repressed but it was really
interesting cuz we talked and I I kind
of finally got him to kind of like not
only admit that but also that it was
[ __ ] okay and that's who he was
and then we had this long talk about it
and I got a I got a I think it was a
letter later on him from him saying I
was a huge no he said that was a huge
that was he thank you for being somebody
who basically owe me it was okay
he said just you know he nobody he
hadn't had anybody give him permission
to be what he was and to say it's okay
and and your dad's wrong or your dad has
the wrong expectations not who you came
out to duty only knew for a few more
well he trusted me I was older
I he he liked me I was I was making him
laugh you know that was a strange and
whole things and everything and then we
then I said well she was like I think
he's gay like really you really go to
dinner yeah yeah I job and dinner young
dude like bro I don't know I know we
don't know each other but how are you
day and I was like he was like yes yeah
and I was like bingo right and then we
fought I was like let's go to my and
then I got a letter were many years
later and I said whoops what's this now
that would be that would be no Jesse
smaller that would be what an older gay
man would do but I was an old a straight
man so whatever didn't happen I won't
think I've had a couple experiences like
that where if I see somebody who's very
because I had when I was a young man my
acting teacher my amazing accident
Richard Pinter I had this [ __ ] very
strong idea of what a man was which was
tough you know be the guy you know no no
no emotion nothing and they he we had an
interview with him this is how [ __ ] up
I was I was 23 I want to be an actor he
said were a nightmare to anything oh
well I was also a nightmare cuz I had no
control away I was just a [ __ ] mess
and and I'm a much bigger mess than you
can imagine like like like in in terms
of confusion about what I wanted to do
with my life just know where to place my
energy and just [ __ ] and he you're
like a big ball of want and you don't
know how to get it you know you just did
so everything's everything's how to
reach 20 of that age let's be honest and
so he goes um he goes to me alright he
said something to me and he said oh that
embarrassed you and I went not it and he
goes yeah it did and that's good it's
okay you kind of let me know that and
then he's a saying on sneakers did I
just got you a little emotional right
and I was like no and he goes it did I'm
gonna teach you that that's just as
manly is not being emotional and that
was the journey of being a [ __ ] actor
like that like allowing you to have
emotions that are yeah but also emotion
if you grow up where emotion is
considered weakness if it's equated with
weakness not good yeah if I don't might
be some people honorable my son gotta
let you sure you playing bass on the
ball him in the face when Christ now he
holds it in I was like hi I'm like what
do you do
damn let it out man what do you I don't
know where the [ __ ] you well you get it
where you got that you know what I think
I'll go and like hold em like what are
you doing your family you're altering
your culture whether you know it or not
if you come from a culture that doesn't
allow for that if you come from a macho
culture if you come from a culture that
didn't have time for that you know like
a lot of times I've been on earth for
three years there's no culture around
him like that well it's just in when
your wife is Mexican there that's a
tough culture you know um without even
knowing it like if you're Russian he's
why yeah yeah well not wire it it's just
that whether you not know it or not
sometimes there's not a lot of you're
not gonna see Russian men crushing kids
there's no time for that chickens no
there's no time
it's a sign of your history would be
that would be a vulnerability if you
show weakness in certain cultures and
you know that just the way it is and so
so straight yeah so whether you know it
or not it get it permeates into
someone's psyche at a very young age not
good good it comes with good and bad
right it comes with like liability as
you know he's not a [ __ ] do it off oh
[ __ ] I'm that well you know those dads
yeah ain't [ __ ] crying that's like
this guy I know is he would hit his son
he would hit his son when he cry and and
he was like what's going on because I
just don't want to be I don't know yeah
I don't want to get I would hit that
he'd hit him like this on the top of the
head or what him though but he goes I
don't want him to be gay so I'm
toughening malo what am literally like
that's hewn from the 1940 he was a that
was how he grew up and he's dump god
when you can have dumb parents who
didn't do their reading in the research
they'll [ __ ] you up you know every
acting teacher will always say no matter
how good your parents are they they get
in the way of your acting maybe we have
to unlearn what you were told
my acting teacher would say this to
people he was [ __ ] brilliant he'd get
out yeah but he'd get a teacher in there
this after teaching people for 40 years
so when you have a guy who's been in
front of his talk for 40 years what he
becomes is what you would think is a
psychic a psychic right a psychic
because he can read human behavior on a
level that you have no idea so the
[ __ ] gotta have a guy in there
to go like this you do the see
the guy sitting there and he go he go
come for me to ask him a couple
questions like I'll watch this whole
accent go with me you want to see a guy
physically how long do you rehearse for
the scene about three weeks three weeks
yeah how many hours would you say three
four hours a day yeah so about an hour a
day but also uh were you from Denver
Denver come from money uh no a lot a lot
that's just in the guy VI and he'd do it
like that he go a lot done not a little
bit a lot right and the guy was like
yeah he goes and let me get something
else you come from a discipline
household your mom always say you guys
start crying start crying because he
could read him right there just like
that or watch this I would see this over
and over watch this he'd go so um so how
are you doing yeah yeah which one of
your parents drank was it both Jesus I
swear to God and you did they just
started crying Kim the next Jeffrey
Tambor and Milton Casals would do [ __ ]
iswe day would do the most uncanny [ __ ]
in the world they go like this they'd go
go um when was the accident you had an
accident was it a car accident
what from their gate what yeah what's
going on none of us all feel like what
was he talking about and the guy looks
terribly like no let me go well what's
going on with your back and your leg
what's going on well no I mean because
what's going on what's happening well I
mean when I was 15 I you know I was in a
body cast for six months and I did that
but I'm over that now no it's no you're
not you you somebody get up there and
start speaking in a in perfect English
and Milton consult with this he'd go um
what other languages in there oh well my
mother's Italian yes there's nothing you
can pick up my glasses or you just you
just you majored in it I haven't been
able to sign up for any because I've
been working so often but I'd like to
get back into it but when you're majored
in it there's yes sir one acting coach
at USC no there's a bunch so so when you
major in act and this all sorts of
different yeah a lot of different
Department yeah and a lot of them are
still working to this day which is
really
there's voiceover teachers who were in
like Finding Nemo
she's on anastasia Broadway right now
Christ one of my teachers was a part of
the first class of Juilliard really
really amazing teachers there if I could
have done it all over again I would have
tried to get into Juilliard her program
do you ever think about doing The
Groundlings I did I would have done that
too cuz I hear Dax Shepard talked about
on his podcast and his group of people
and like the levels that want to get
there and all the people that were in it
Taran Killam they just talked about it
and my [ __ ] that'd be cool Taran Killam
was in it so I might the number one
group I recommend the people is The
Groundlings whenever I say to people I
go they go I want to take acting class
at the groundlings because so many
people that work went to the groundings
they're all I've worked with so many of
them I continued to work with many of
them on my teaching I hope that so
Groundlings is basically the Alabama for
improv that's right so in the NFL they
always pick everyone from Alabama well
Saturday Night Live picked their own
from the ground yeah name me any one
that's been alive second city my second
city uh Upright Citizens Brigade and The
Groundlings but the ground who did the
ground wings like alumni it's insane
when I hear uh Dax talk about on his
podcast when he goes into detail about
and the people who worked with him the
grind all that stuff it makes it makes
me regret not doing it you're like that
but me too why but you you be kind of I
went to theater school but if I could
have done it all over again my biggest
mistake was going to American University
and studying history I would have gone
to a proper theater school and learned
to sing dance I would have done
Shakespeare I would act that I would
have written I would have done it all so
you look good and uh if you go back to
chin is so yeah Kristen Wiig Melissa
McCarthy Paul Reubens Lisa Kudrow Phil
Hartman
Kaitlin Olson Dax Shepard I mean Maya
Rudolph Maya Rudolph's up Maya Rudolph
is so much better than people even
realize my ruin off can do everything
Kaitlin Olson is so unbelievable I was
talking to uh I was talking to [ __ ]
night and by the way easy on the eyes
but healing also yeah I her man her
man's robbed from Always Sunny the cause
he creator and I was on a plane with
those two
and I put my foot in my mouth because
when they're talking about shooting in
Dublin I was like Jesus Christ always
said in Philadelphia really blew up
honey gets really sold out and they're
like oh no we're sorry we're not with
Always Sunny where they created a game
of Thrones I mean that's cool
I'll stay forward oh do I thank you
you're like an idiot I don't know who
anyone is
that's hilarious and I don't watch the
game with no that's how but I try
talking dragon so that's that's that's
the guy that is the guy from Sonny
always Sonny oh he's the creative yeah
he's brilliant he's also muscular he put
on you got huge jacked well he got fat
for the foot heavy is the final story so
that's got fat on purpose and went to a
doctor and the doctors like so you need
this much every two hours of this and he
didn't get fat fast enough so he goes
[ __ ] this I'm sure I need all the
calories I can get so he started
drinking milkshakes in the middle of
night and melted ice cream so he put on
all this weight and then now he's gotten
like in better shape like I was like
actually pretty jacked why did he get so
fat what was it just funny but he want
the entire cast to do it and they're all
[ __ ] know she's a [ __ ] all doing
that's awesome and it's funny cuz
character it's he's hilarious brilliant
man and him and Dax Shepard were talking
about cuz Dax goes Axios it's funny
because he was we're both in shape now
and he asked his wife she was on the
show she goes did you notice when Rob
put on all that weight did you care she
goes I didn't give a [ __ ]
look now she was I love Rob you know I
he looks the same to me I don't even
notice and it's true look at him look at
him now its foot in that's gotta be some
help right he looks great though how
funny is it though that's what I can do
with steroids I'll do it how funny is it
though
but they're talking about how really
only guys notice a change in someone's
body like girls really don't give a [ __ ]
yeah Chael Sonnen was on that you had a
UFC episode that's superhero Jack that's
not him like all the time that's him
just for that yeah
what is he doing there that's so cool so
funny so inappropriately muscular it was
either way have you seen Always Sunny in
Philadelphia
no I've never seen one episode my needs
are hot dude one of the greats
that's just silent awesome
it's funny when he got fat but Tom
muscle quick
he's Mises Christ man he got both on
what their sixteenth season he's the
creator much money that homeboys making
uh yeah you make create the show crazy
and then then you know the rest of its
life
it had like a cult following like the
first year - yeah and then FX they're
like right no one's really watching this
but we believe in the product they go we
need to bring on like a big name to get
people to watch and so you know the
three of them are all best friends the
three guys oh they are they're the best
yeah so they're like no we're not this
is our project man we're not allowing
anyone in like I wanna bring on Danny
DeVito it's a big name and he can ride
them into it so they bring on Danny
DeVito and they thought that would like
bringing all these eyeballs it still
didn't do that well and then finally
just caught on because I'd like an
underground fault is so good I'm a
seasoned water on that guy I gotta watch
it oh it can watch it it is [ __ ] :
gotta watch there's nothing like it
I know that guy a little bit the Dennis
system do you watch a chin no I see
little clips of it it's really really
good oh my god nothing makes me laugh
hard raagh that a big mouth me Helen
scene that he looks a lot like Haley
Joel Osment he was on the episode - no
he does huh yeah but the [ __ ] homeboy
blew up behind him if you go back so the
you know the guy on the back right he
been Charlie Dan Charlie dave blew the
[ __ ] up
Caitlin also has a spinoff on Fox called
the Mick
and obviously Rob's the creator of the
show and then it's goddamn Danny DeVito
then the other guy has his own spin-off
- Dennis as don't spin off - called a
AE or something like that a science a
either a pea or some like it's a about
he's a teacher
Damon auditioned for one of their
spin-offs it was so funny so fun sons of
anarchy
well that's effect there's nothing to do
with always sunny dude doesn't well
there you go
she do some kind of that it's due to her
and Oliver Elms saw some curls okay so
yesterday news broke that Tristan Thomas
and Khloe Kardashian are separated
because he cheated on her with Kylie's
best friend and this is a girl that was
raised around Chloe as well ever since
they were up with the family surfing
best friend yeah another Tristan
Thompson just like stuff [ __ ]
well he got caught before when she was
pregnant that girl was hot yeah my god
yeah and then he just got caught with
the family's best friend a lot of you
are outraged about this because she said
I've seen about this morning that girls
kind of [ __ ] actually I'm the
Kardashian clan is so intense like if
you go against them they're so intense
so that's best friend on the riots
particle mmm-hmm she's so fake like if
you saw her early in the season she's
got so much work done it in her own the
right yeah their before and after photos
where she looks very dashing she grew up
with Kardashian's of course Kylie Bailey
for everything
Kylie has uh helped her one get a new
body would let you helped her career
because she helps funds these little
things that her best friend wants to use
me excuse me sir yeah now this is what
and that does she deserve to get all
this backlash stuff like that but you
know who knows but Jesus Christ really
stepped her game up
god bless doctors so the thing is is
come on nutrition she's young Tristan
Thompson comes along throws that big MBA
dick her way she [ __ ] him she's gonna
she's [ __ ] man if you go to Instagram
I bet it's so evil right so that's Kylie
Jenner that's the one who got all the
working Talia went hey I get this great
doctor and make you into a dime piece
you down a dude
pay for it she's like yeah sure I'm I
look like [ __ ] let me do it she's a lot
of modeling jobs after she got her
surgeries - after Kyla paid for all of
that she saw popping on hot bliss she
also lost weight worked out right I mean
nope
it's called lipo I just signed all of it
so strange now there she is
yes the right she's gorgeous there she
took all doing no first a christened Tom
we know for a fact oh yeah load
comfortable this morning and then there
are other best friends also confirmed it
this morning
wine all this I have no idea Brian so
look at her she was busted look at those
teeth and then just a doctor went let me
let me get my hands on yeah doosh doosh
doosh 10 I mean a lot of people are
saying that this is ironic because she's
still Khloe Kardashian's baby daddy the
same way Kylie stole blac Chyna's baby
daddy oh wow and the credit yeah Khloe
also a Kardashian also was under fire
when she first started dating Tristan
because he left his pregnant girlfriend
at the time to be with her he loves
Geoff Irene and a bunch of fun Tristan
did yes and then he cheated on her when
she was pregnant and she don't know when
it comes down to it people just like the
[ __ ] don't they yeah and also um girls
that want to [ __ ] Tristan no he's a very
handsome dude oh and he's looking at all
he's seven foot dick the size of your
von I don't know that's that's why
you're jumping to conclusions this dick
might be bigger than me now let's see I
could jump on his dick and [ __ ] it like
there is no other way I would be able to
do it well like a sling [ __ ] can you not
say that Simpson don't talk about our
intern blew this house she left do it
I'm begging you tell us to do like she's
a baby son
I'm not listening I'm not listening I'm
not listening at all this thing about a
person
hey wait let me see Tristan Thompson
there is he's a very good-looking dude
um yeah yeah well Tristan Tristan likes
he likes variety and girls no he just
likes to [ __ ] bro yeah yeah he's got a
great personality he's got a regular
house personality is might be a [ __ ] saw
six inch tall six inch in your dreams my
dream dresses well so he's he married he
was married to that girl right Khloe
Kardashian him were they married they
were never married they were dating
no heat so he cheated on her and there's
video he's cheating on I've seen this
video of him cheating on her when she
was like alright I'll swap in that Club
oh yeah so he's got a guy goes how could
you so how could you have this is
ridiculous oh yeah look at bro you
didn't know that you had surveillance no
he didn't I would assume I'm good too
bro how he's gonna release this now is
this a strip club or work that looks
like a hotel lobby which is frowned upon
now would you know when you with hope
right but you got some made that video
that's a private video that seems like
you're right yeah what did TMZ some
stupid [ __ ] that works at the hotel
who's like [ __ ] Tristan Thompson he
missed that too pointed in the [ __ ]
NBA Finals three years ago if I check it
out of tanzy that's what God you know
attrition should go up walk up that guy
wrap his huge [ __ ] around his neck and
choke him out
tied around his neck yep like a goddamn
I mean can't you sue as well for making
that [ __ ] hey yeah
but also damage is done damage is done
go and Sue him I mean to his defense he
tried to be better about it that she was
all upon his cockatiel there look at
that girl really the guy's just sitting
there he's only a man and they're all
lonely
I mean they're all gorgeous they're all
gorgeous and look it's their tits in his
face how do you know I feel bad for him
- his hands grab his chute [ __ ] and
laughing and high-fiving the other girls
bro actually I have some people to have
he's a victim you know what he is he's
afraid he's the mountain lion that guy
[ __ ] killed
Laurette they're grabbing is gone oh god
it's a me tube movement yeah we just
started [ __ ] porn by the way by the
way by the way I have I've heard that
athletes like that
get a lot of that from girls am i
wrought maybe I'm wrong I must be Ron
might be around girls aren't and why
because he's impossibly giant [ __ ] and
these girls like when he's a
multi-millionaire and he's really good
at what he does I feel bad for why I
said it I feel bad for him I don't envy
him well I love the professional hot
girls they're great look at this hanging
out he pulls are they professionals or
they just awesome Brian right they're
just great awesome girls or they just
they're whoo girls whoo that's all there
are no feel good girls they're American
girls what's wrong with being an
American last time I checked this is a
free country is this Russia man can
enjoy himself in a hole Jesus look at
him he's trying to be good to look at
this I feel bad for him yeah
he's keeping homes - and then the poor
guy is at the Kardashian's house and
their hot friend who's had all the work
done searched on her tits in his faith
and he's like he's saying he's saying
nothing and then you're [ __ ] the bad
guys they're grabbing at his rod I feel
bad for him yeah I also made everybody
get rid of their phones if they wanted
to stay stick around that night my heart
does that them he did mm-hmm
my heart goes it's gotta be safe he's
trying to be good and then he just you
got and you got [ __ ] in a hotel or
wherever that was
and then you trap him in his room you're
like we're not leaving till we suck you
off and he's like what he's only one he
didn't want to be rude so I feel bad I
feel I feel for him so so now he's for
now this resistant the problem is this
guys having sex with his girl's friends
now so he old best man so he hit he was
hitting no Zoey
- don't say heading can younger older
and she's having sex with Hugh so he was
he was engaged and had a kid with Chloe
cheat on her while she's pregnant they
get over that you know what they're
gonna figure it out you know I'll give
him a freebie okay I guess I'll pass now
he's back in the house then his sister's
best friend gets all this work done
searched on her [ __ ] around his way
and they yet [ __ ] so she was in the
house and she was friends with Chloe
yeah I'm a family friend family friend
best friends with her sister and
apparently now she's getting evicted
from Kylie's house well yeah hey Kylie
be a little understanding now you'd have
to kick her out but also also do you
have to kick her out your house is so
big can she not live in the left branch
I've never seen these girls are dating
these high profile athletes because they
get something out of it - it's like they
date very strategically so let's not be
the Kardashian hold on here though
Tristan Thompson really not that famous
we started dating Chloe she has so much
more money than him yeah he definitely
benefits way more from all these
attractive you get looking D's a very
good-looking do out whatever meanwhile
whatever also I feel bad for all his
friends are like all this boys are like
ours boys are like dude really the first
time you get caught while she's pregnant
now you [ __ ] the best friend in the
house that's dumb
that's not cool I don't find the
Kardashians it's very pivotal at all
really Kylie and Kendall and I mean just
all that work it doesn't do a thing for
me I don't like it I do not find them
attractive no yeah she's hideous
she's beautiful but like then I see the
poor before after I'm like I don't give
a [ __ ] oh I can just see no fan ID him
that's all I see I'd like to see it
wrapped oh my god and I know that they
are interested in me and I just yeah oh
dude you know what that you're their
style not giant famous black athletes
older or scrawny white dudes yeah that's
I mean you can use a bottle dude you're
spot-on
yeah you're tired and now I just want to
say that I know that you guys are into
me
I'm not doing I'm too small for Chloe
yeah I'm too small for her she likes a
big large man she does she does with now
Kim likes a big soft body that's fine I
yeah
Kanye playin yellow but he's also kind
of like you know as famous as it gets to
he was also crazy and bipolar so I'm
sure there's some issues probably he has
well girls sorry what else we got I feel
bad for so Burberry is in the news
because they released a sweater on for
the runway show that had a noose as like
the drawstrings and people are mad hi
this is getting Whitney's wouldn't he
comes and bond what yeah she released a
tweet
looks like Wanda Sykes before okay did
you [ __ ] get together and asked how
can we make this the worst Black History
Month ever I mean let's really [ __ ] it
up and then Whitney says hey fashion
people I'm just an unstylish comedian
who doesn't know anything but maybe
laughs the black face and news is for a
while they're starting to feel like some
weird bet about who can go out of
business the fastest well that's funny
III think Whitney's Whitney just being
funny yeah she's being silly
I don't I don't see it being a big
problem I mean but I would say it's poor
choice to put a noose around the collar
but yeah I know I'm not gonna not by
Burberry yeah I know that is like it's
somebody I'd be like hey dude that's a
noose and we've been it also doesn't
look good does it make sense yeah also
some people affiliate that with racism
yeah I just do something else yeah you
know I mean yeah but I'm not gonna
[ __ ] it does feel like they're like
let's see if we can get away with yeah
it's like it's almost like you know what
that is it's a marketing of course I was
like let's just sing outrage we'll get a
lot of press and then we'll apologize
but it's good press that's what else
yeah you're probably right dude
devious hey what's this John Wayne
racist stuffed is that in there she has
it ready because I know it's all someone
go Santino goes so should dig John Wayne
up and tell me to apologize so yeah he's
joking ah see there was somebody that
released a bunch of little snippets from
John Wayne's Playboy interview from 1971
was were the times
and my grandma was racist as [ __ ] me
okay yes okay perspective well I'm
Leslie do the story that he tells that
because I don't know what happened yeah
so somebody took a photo of these little
snippets and it's stuff that wouldn't be
okay today but so there's one that says
what kind of films do you consider
perverted Oh Easy Rider Midnight Cowboy
that kind of thing wouldn't you say that
the wonderful love of these two men in
Midnight Cowboy a story of two [ __ ]
qualifies but don't get me wrong as far
as a man and woman is concerned
I'm awfully happy there's a thing called
sex it's an extra special something God
gave us I see no reason why it shouldn't
be in pictures healthy lust lusty sex is
wonderful and then he goes into saying
stuff about black people and how he
doesn't want to give blacks power
because they're ignorant right now and
that they need time to catch up before
they should be it was a lot of blogs
there's quite a lot of resentment along
with their dissent and possibly
rightfully so but we can't all of a
sudden get down on our knees and turn
everything over to the leadership of the
blacks I believe in white supremacy oh
geez so the blacks are educated to a
point of responsibility I don't believe
in giving authority and positions of
leadership and judgment to irresponsible
people you tell me the white guy in the
[ __ ] 70s and when a pilgrims isn't
racist it's just the [ __ ] land of the
races the land are you equipped to judge
which blocks are responsible which of
their leaders and experience it's not my
judgment the academic communities
develop certain tests to determine
whether the blacks were sufficiently
equipped scholastically but some blacks
have tried to force the issue and to
college when they haven't passed the
test and don't have the requisite
background so so just keep keep in mind
that this is 1971 mmm-hmm when did when
was the civil rack Rights Act passed
does anybody know know you know though
1960 1964
where's made illegal and all that yes so
around this time no so literally you're
talk about a guy who grew up in a in
institutional racism where blacks and
whites in the South certainly weren't
even allowed but also drink from the
season of this what is the point of
digging up old John Wayne [ __ ] god those
let's ruin this guy even though he's
passed away in this so long ago those
were the time yeah and he was saying
things that back then that were you know
considered to be true where's the cry
for Richard Pryor and stuff like that
being gay and leading women stuff like
that like who gives a [ __ ] that was the
it's arts gone man this is this is this
is a change in now this is gonna educate
this is that this is what we're living
in now and there are people who are
looking for any sign of racism or any
side of anything think about the [ __ ]
dork who went through all these
interviews then brought up was like
check it out guys yeah let's jump on
this one that was the world we lived in
and we and by the way the he was on the
education by the way we have gotten to a
point where there is less racism
worldwide and Steven Pinker makes a
great case for that in his book and
Lightman now the the n-word is googled
far less across the board all over the
world then than it ever has been that's
significant and it's only in fact it's
only googled by older people you can
tell by their social security number for
jokes looking for jokes that and we're
jokes and it's just not done anymore
used to be constantly you know so so we
are making progress and that's to a lot
of brave people who went out there and
did all their stuff what do you think
there are a lot of people who agree with
you guys as well it seems like there's
two groups the group that's outraged
that he said this and another group were
like wait that was set in 1917 people do
know you know that the Russians did you
see that yeah that podcast the Russians
are involved in these yeah they're the
ones like it's like create a lot of this
to Autobots and trolls that get it going
yeah they could they they'd they staged
protests the Russians are staging
protests between like you know people
who are anti vaccine versus Roe vaccine
they're just they're trying to sow
dissension through via internet what
else you guidance this right here it's a
[ __ ] you Russians so Meek Mill and
Michael Rapaport are in a beef right now
because Michael Rapaport tweeted
something along the lines of meek being
trash as a wrap
and meek responded with a couple of
tweets saying that he doesn't know who
he is and that he shouldn't be speaking
on the culture and Michael Rapaport
responded back saying that he is trash
because he can't rap on beat and that he
got dragged by Drake and anyone who gets
dragged by Drake is trash this is what
rap does though like you just wants to
create pure chaos
so like greens on this show there's
gonna be 900 negative comments and 100
positive comments that he just likes to
be relevant exceed Oz yeah Asli shaking
the tree don't you [ __ ] who offends me
out me yeah who's this anonymous I think
it's the guy from the white men can't
jump him me you so far you give me that
feeling with hip hop is missing on my
fan
can I get selfie hurry up go ahead oh
he's making fun I'm taking picture rap
what's his round form you get dragged by
Drake and don't respond you're always
will be whack at least make it
competitive free up some people it's
people catching feelings because you
know I'm right about Meek Mill Meek Mill
have a hearing problem because his
rhymes are off actually beat it all
right I don't know I don't know no no I
found comfortable michael is so funny
ariana grande went up Pete Davidson made
fun of all like he's always he goes he
goes hard but he's also like that guy I
like said he has a stance yeah like I
might not agree with him but I like that
he goes hard in the paint while everyone
else is walking on this type rope and
being [ __ ] afraid he will push back
he doesn't care I've seen him in New
York [ __ ] loses his minds know what
else you got
just some more updates on Jesse Smollett
so the dudes the brothers are supposed
to testify yesterday in front of a grand
jury and then the last minute they got a
phone call the course had a phone call
like you know we have a change of plans
so I guess Jesse smallest defense team
contacted him saying that Jesse will
speak to the you know the police and
everyone that wants to talk to him you
know he's like trying to push it off for
a while so as soon as there's about the
test of I've got the lawyers should say
oh he's gonna speak about it he's gonna
go to the cops because they didn't want
the dudes from
yeah yeah they don't want them to
testify he's so that's so [ __ ]
here's the thing where he's super [ __ ]
that people aren't thinking of so in the
fake note that he created he ground up
tylenol and made it seem like it was you
know so that's a felony so there's that
so I thought he'd just get like parole
or just be good like they obviously it's
careers tarnish but when you do that now
now your tears tarnish are over cuz I
would say it's over I over yeah yeah
this day and age they're like well like
we said before reality TV
he could still I don't know something
bad but so they dug up this stuff to
from his past so I think 2008 2007 he
had a DUI the reason why this is
interesting is because he didn't have
his ID on him right his driver's license
so he said he was his little brother he
pretended to be his little brother and
he got convicted of DUI so he that might
just be him because he just landed may
be a big show and his brother but still
he's your little brother it's [ __ ] up
you don't do that yeah it's not cool
yeah that it though
almost and then I'm sure you guys know
this but they're supposed to film a few
episodes and they're cutting a few
episodes because of this stuff is going
on it's gonna be a hard path put them in
Empire now yeah you done done done there
say they're still saying they're
supporting a moose well you know core
shows are still supporting him Cory
Booker and camel Harris who the
politicians who like I will make
lynching a federal hate crime they went
hard now they're like they're like oh no
oh
exactly so anyways looks we integrate
support for Empire sorry I'm in question
about this case I'm sure they have to
see there's just you know they have
sense and as soon as the official
official the yeah he's done done hmm
alright so uh but my 6r Pound life
started on milk and dies why did you
actually know who you were pounds what
do you actually knew he wasn't or I've
watched the episode of horse he died
because he ate seven box of Lucky Charms
a day wow I can barely get through to
died at 29 that's so young though he is
thick
someone else she got shut up too thick
boy all right tennis legend Martina
Navratilova so she was serving as a
board member for athletes Ally athlete
ally which is a pioneer yeah awesome
she's also a lesbian see gay community
was like mad
wait why don't they want her so that is
an LGBTQ organization and she served as
an advisor on the board and now they let
her go because of her comments about if
you're transitioning from a man to a
woman and want to compete with women she
doesn't believe that's fair I don't need
right I don't say my saying it she said
it's insane it's cheating
correct I agree with her and so they
took her off the [ __ ] they said that's
transphobic oh yeah of course they did
and that's why those extremists who are
in that they're extremists they don't
speak for the whole trans community they
just [ __ ] extremists they're
activists who are not interested in
truth or anything else they're just
extremists and [ __ ] them so what they're
just a loud bunch of [ __ ] and they
[ __ ] sever ties with that badass that
[ __ ] legend who knows more about
sports and I was [ __ ] people but she
could send a tweet out she can go
further than anything that the LGBTQ
she's a huge name yeah and so it doesn't
really matter if anything it hurts them
but they did that's how they are they're
too dumb they're idiots they're it's a
[ __ ] and by the way she's right she's
right it's unfair of course of course
true so but you haven't done sports so
they don't know that high level she
knows she's got I got this this is
possibly good for the Asians that guy
the lead character for crazy rotations
they said that he's on a short list of
people being considered for the next
Bond
when Daniel Craig finishes the world is
changing so 10 idris elba yeah I heard
Tom Hardy to some other ones I feel that
would be interesting right would you
hardest is short I feel like Tom Hardy's
know I love time I don't feel like skip
on that guy seems cool I guess bond has
to be I think now so that guy feels to
do you know it's my problem a crazy why
not white white but why can't it be
double-oh-seven why can't it be double
o8 double nine
why not just create your own franchise
do double o8 don't want because
double-oh-seven
there's six agents before him we know
that's right so why not do double O
eight double a nine and make them Asian
black and Korean was not be doing that
point well they could never do that
because it has to be [ __ ] done so I
think he's too
he's just too sweet nice too sweet and
not tough enough to he doesn't seem
tough at all to be double awesome you
would have to see her cell Elroy's yeah
I feel like it's pretty I think it's
awesome for the role
I do think he'd be awesome for me I hate
be Grayson Statham would be cool but
it's too on the nose yeah I eat just out
but I can see doing even Bradley Cooper
I think Cooper have to be English yeah I
don't know who you could get for them it
doesn't matter
white boys you're out yeah so well yeah
I know I don't know about lights out
guys to whites out man
he does look too kind too nice but for
me go Asian
he's also like I'm all he was crazy I'm
not gonna go too
you know I'm saying no you're saying get
in there like if I'm if I'm eating
[ __ ] Korean barbeque I'm not going to
[ __ ] the white people scream bottom I
don't go in full Koreatown barbecue yeah
where I don't know what is his
nationality is he mixed Singaporean is
he he's I believe Chinese Chinese and
was a Dutch yeah though he's white he's
half white though yeah it's for a while
you're out bro we're if we're gonna put
a minority as bond you gotta be full I
want him like you want it like we barely
understand what's going on yeah she's
not stud British Malaysian British
British though dude
all right we need to go [ __ ] deep all
right does it look tougher here no too
soft
he's not tight I don't want that guy
saving America you know I'm saying like
I don't want him saving [ __ ] the CIA
I don't buy it bond just ooh he's too
pretty
yeah too pretty he's just too pretty
who'd be good
Sean Connery when he was younger dude
somebody ain't gonna ring up Sean
Connery's
oh please don't we've gotten over this
one time yes dying and he's retired
trump card
Sean cards not gonna work and also he
was born for fun say yes he was um who
would be good for double is seven um I
mean I don't mind the Bradley Cooper
thing
no would you want an Englishman you want
anyway um I love Tom Hardy but he's I
mean IIIi think Christian Bale could
pull it off nope nope nope no no Daniel
day-lewis oh no damn I think that's
indie let's go he was back out yeah what
about Liam Neeson no simply too old and
we've seen him taken seven time I'd go
off the radar I wouldn't do someone
really famous that's a good point and
I'd go so astok actually I'd get like a
[ __ ] what about are more like Francis
and gah no type it's just chocolate yeah
what about Armie Hammer army hammers a
giant man I think I believe he's very
tall and he's very good-looking
oh they said Henry Cavill too man
yeah yeah I don't I don't like him as
much as an actor I just don't he doesn't
do it he doesn't harass me he was
Superman I didn't you didn't do it for
me him as Gina crowns boyfriend really
didn't do it for me um yeah he's not
he's not charismatic
that guy is charismatic that guy's
Harmon slammer oh yeah he's real was
really good Man From UNCLE he's really
good he's tough he's a big and strong
that's my prom he's not tough he's a
pole Armie Hammer maybe I believed he
was tough in that when he played that
agent yeah he played the nice book to
him you know he's not yeah he did he's
great in that he's not rugged enough
weed rugged we need Rahl I think he can
pull it off I really do him have a Clive
Owen he's a lot older than two old bro
oh uh any other brain Buster's use any
cream people where I think enough Korean
people know there's no one that's like
huge it has to be some sort of a stature
right you don't want like someone's you
want some pounds on him call you know
you're rich you know rain right who rain
be
Ninja Assassin mm-hmm it's tough kind of
tough
I would go off the grid and find someone
find someone just some of this guy not
that guy he's too much of a he's a pop
star too though yeah he's too skinny
he's too thin too sexy too girlish yeah
he's like two dopes there though yeah
you know I don't know we're not gonna
figure it out what else we got we need
someone rugged and tough every champion
so ethnic like super ethnic where you're
like What did he say
like Inuit like what dude like so a bond
like Congo like oh dude like deep Africa
and but in like deep something deep
Africa deep Alaska yeah and but he's
he's amazed by taxis like he's not even
used to that yeah you want fresh off
them you want you want Dayak you want
you want yeah adaiah community jie put
in da like why a que you give me die ax
were the original die ax were
headhunters back in the day not that
Indonesia yeah I lived with them I lived
under my Spencer yeah I don't say you
lived with them I did take a look at
some at home on you say that visit I
spent two days with them drink wine with
them dance with them all yeah they would
be great ball hockey no and bro well I
just got yet aro chin on the side just
keep going going going
hold on I'm talking about Dayak
[ __ ] yeah no that's not my bond
you wanted to go super ethnic bro how
this is stupid you wanted to go ethnic
hope you this hard she would be good as
James Bond look at the eerie goodness
look at the ants nothing else how pull
down those ears are so many cultures
stretch their body with all different
kinds I like really put the plates in
their lips now let's see that plate lips
you guys mostly the lip plates I guess
man you know all's you don't have the
balls to have somebody with plates in
their lips
I'll make him that X bond this is nice
pot oh well there is damn shaking not
stirred
now the problem is how do you eat you
don't what is stuff what in the actual
[ __ ] is gonna live like that you know I
mean what in the dude is so smart to do
do human beings do it's so smart to do
that look at all that that's without the
plate that's crazy
look its ass hits on it you got in that
is insane oh my god like a white their
teeth how do you eat that her teeth are
better than ours right yeah but how do
you eat you just shovel it and dude it's
like a plate it's right on your plate I
mean some crazy [ __ ] people do some
crazy [ __ ] she's pretty
it's cool look at the look at this
[ __ ] ears terrible idea Minh it's a
terrible idea
that's not scary at all at night don't
walk away oh my god leave [ __ ] it be
over that is amazing how the [ __ ] would
you eat I guess you'd take the plate out
take to play it out and slurp it up oh
god that's hard to watch yeah let me see
can you go back let me just see that
Barret there it is now that's hard to
kissy-kiss with that just keep just the
top lip okay okay I don't think they
kissed it what else kitchen all right
this is from that fire festival you guys
heard that part where he's talking about
he would do whatever he had to to get
the Avion water bottles yeah didn't he
say some yeah you want to watch that
real quick so this is a power set in the
dock everyone tells me to watch it so I
don't watch it so this is the event
planner and there was a last-minute
thing they they asked him to do I'm not
gonna talk about that but containers
fill for 18-wheeler trucks filled with
Evian water he said Andy if you will go
down and suck Cunningham's - who's the
head of cop customs drove home to
shower III drank some mouthwash and then
I got to his office fully prepared to
suck his dick
and I had all the water that we needed
so that was a story I absolutely love
that guy that's a dude what now as of
the as a result of that confession he's
getting all these different TV deals and
movie deals and everything else that's
we said oh he's hilarious and he's
awesome
that is a bad mother funny Dan employee
like those oh no me takes one for the
team
drive across the island just even though
you that is incredible I took a shower
it's a mouth wash Irma he's like that's
like cuz they don't do ya ya do dad just
like so I drove down there radius and
that Billy that's the guy with the
waters I get him trying it my dick sucks
so no way you get this I don't I release
it and the older straight man is I won't
release it unless you take care of the
kid I've never seen that that's Holly
it's so funny so it's paying off for him
though so he says awesome what else uh
this is not so much of a all right I
guess it's kind of care of that but Ken
Jong he has a special lot and listen
look at the title of the special you
could complete mijo isn't that crazy
I know but still that's the last name I
know but I think is when you watch it
people don't know that right they think
he's saying ho that's freaking cool
pretty cool just changed it I saw part
of it yeah in the beginning he's very
aggressive yeah he goes hard oh there's
a bunch of hos in rent he's just doing
crowd work he's a twitching she's all
huh oh he's like what that [ __ ] what's
your name Shaco he's like how many holes
are in there in his life in the back I
think there's the big as oh his wife's
just like in the back it's great the
thighs have to yeah nice house yeah he
goes hard in the paint he goes hard
I love says the F word a lot I love it
yeah I love it comics I don't like [ __ ]
comics what else you want some more I'd
give us one more should we end on Kim
Jong um there's this is a Sports one
that guy Le'Veon Bell that you talked
about a lot I guess he's gonna be a free
agent now finally Amon Antonio Brown are
both gonna be out there you go boom bow
boom buh-buh-buh-buh that's it guys
that's it here we go dude that's it and
I do very clear yeah never say I would
drive across the island suck dick for
you dude thank you buddy I appreciate it
I want you to know if you ever need me
to do that I'm gonna do that too and I
want you to know one thing what if we
were dying a thirst I was like a day
they all suck your dick to quench my
thirst um you know what else what's that
buddy I would drive to Milwaukee to suck
dick because I'm gonna be in my gonna be
in Milwaukee get tickets are on sale yep
okay let's get them on sale pronto but
let me just just you'd feel it out for
you guys it's definitely not on yet but
they just schedule it today it's my
first time in Milwaukee and is that a
theater the Turner hall
that's Milwaukee March 22nd and 23rd one
show on the 22nd which is a Friday one
show on the 23rd which is a Saturday
Milwaukee Wisconsin I have never been
and this is a giant theater let's do my
walking I will suck off everybody if
they'll sell out go just line up boys
I'm a suck y'all mm-hmm there you go
that's not true I'm not suck off anyone
but Milwaukee I'm coming Miami March 15
through the 16th then the following week
I'm in Milwaukee on the 21st and 22nd
then Washington DC at the three weeks in
a round fantastic I'm gonna retire it
also March 28th through the 30th I'm in
Washington DC get your tickets now d5k
calm Brian tell me what you're sucking
people off at you know what buddy I'm
gonna be in Vancouver tomorrow at the
VOC theater we are almost sold out mmm
Vancouver VOC theater tomorrow for the
Just for Laughs festival Salt Lake City
March 1 and 2 I'm there at wise guys and
then the Kansas City improv never been
looking forward to it all being can help
new markets for some young artists 22
and March 23 do we're talking Road Dawgs
we're but we're all back to back aren't
we back at the back to back that's it
that's it get us I'm in Philly after
that I'm in Philly aw God
goddamn it I'm in I'm gone every weekend
I'm in Philly March 20 28 29 30 so yeah
we've got a we're gonna be busy
brennon we're busy
we busy we busy we come and we busy and
becoming we come in like Tristan
Thompson we busy becoming we coming all
up on The Electrician Thompson your baby
baby coming we come in where's your best
friend coz we come in be common teef at
kcon for tickets for Brian and myself
this apart kid we're out yeah